les bureaux de la Société de l'assurance
automobile du Québec tourner au ralenti
plusieurs services sont suspendus
jusqu'au 20 février durant cette période
impossible d'immatriculer un véhicule de
renouveler un permis de conduire ou une
carte d'assurance maladie et les examens
de conduite théoriques par exemple sont
suspendus
qu'il y a pas de service qu'au 20
février Angelo a perdu la plaque
d'immatriculation sur sa voiture il ne
peut donc plus l'utiliser pendant trois
semaines alors je suis avec tes
problèmes
on est conscient qu'on sollicite
beaucoup la collaboration puis la
patience de la clientèle pion on les on
les remercie la SAQ est en plein virage
numérique tel qu’on sait la semaine
dernière la plateforme s'acclick verra
le jour le 20 février plusieurs services
et documents seront disponibles en ligne
mais d'ici là les systèmes informatiques
sont inutilisables
à la salle qui est certain date de 40
ans donc faut migrer toutes donner
l'offre faire un peu le ménage il y a
des doublons de migrer tout ça pour
entre ça notre nouveau
service
les concessionnaires ne peuvent donc
plus immatriculer les véhicules vendus
c'est pas idéal mais on vive avec on va
essayer de faire le mieux quand même il
remettront au client une attestation de
transaction ce que les particuliers ne
peuvent pas faire le marché du véhicule
usagé entre particuliers qui risquent
d'être mis sur pause à ce moment bref
seuls les services jugés essentiels sont
maintenus comme le remplacement d'un
permis de conduire perdu mais cette dame
l'attend depuis plus d'un mois son
permis provisoire à expirer
sont fermés les inconvénients posés par
cette suspension de service sont donc
bien réelles tous s'entendent pour dire
que le virage numérique effectué par la
SAAQ sera bénéfique c'est en quelque
sorte un mauvais moment à passer avant
d'y arriver ici Sébastien Desrosiers
Radio-Canada Montréal